we're all trying to get through this
time right now as best we can
i know that this must be nice for you
your father
has moved much closer to you he lives
here in los angeles now doesn't he yeah
my dad and my stepmom janice that's cool
is it nice i mean do you get to see your
dad all the time now and does he like it
here
he loves it it's so funny because i
never think of la as a city but he goes
i never lived in a city before you know
like
cause that's right because he was uh he
was in
new hampshire which there's no i mean
if you can get four trees together you
know like that's the city feel but
that's it
yeah did i ever tell you this one time
he goes when i first moved out here
this is just a boxton a boston accent
story but he goes where do you keep your
tax stuff and i go
i keep it in a drawer and then he makes
fun of me and goes oh you keep it in a
drawer
you keep it in a drawer
[Music]
yeah how do you spell that
i go d-r-a-w-e-r and he goes
he's [ __ ] me
[Laughter]
we no one can speak correctly and he
rides a little uh he's got a little um
like adult tricycle what you know those
like adult tricycles
no i haven't seen that he won't get a
rascal
because that's what old people ride
right
he loves his triceps right he doesn't
want to be humiliated by riding a rascal
so he got a big tricycle yeah and
decorated
um you've said before that you enjoy
occasionally
uh smoking uh pot with your dad is that
still the case
we've smoked we just smoked on saturday
actually
after um we have every saturday
we have a um backyard you know we'll get
um sandwiches or whatever and i've got
three sisters out here they're partners
my dad my stepmom and we are in the
backyard
and um after dinner this time we passed
around to join it was good
oh that's nice and your dad your dad
took a few puffs yeah like a champ
i mean it's crazy i he barely even
coughed
and then my stepmother doesn't like to
put smoke in her lungs
so rory my boyfriend
gave her rory's the new guy the
boyfriend cool
he gave janice a uh edible
and then we forgot about it then we're
sitting around he's got a fire pit
and he was sitting like here rory's
rory's on the ground
yeah where he's like you know we're just
kind of running she's on a chair and all
of a sudden she
looks at rory and she goes are you
giving me a pedicure
and we just look at each other and we're
like oh yeah
you forgot it's it's starting to kick
in it starts she says the best things
when she's on an edible she'll go like
i can feel my clothes